you grew up in a dysfunctional household
on welfare you've talked about this
before what war for you personally
psychologically some difficult moments
in your childhood
I'll answer that question in a slightly
different way which is that
I think when you grow up
in a household that's defined by
physical
abuse and psychological abuse
you're hyper Vigilant all the time
and so it's actually easier for me to
point to moments where I was happy
or I felt Compassion or I felt safe
otherwise every moment I'll give you a
couple of examples like
you know I was thinking about this a
while ago
there was a tree outside of my apartment
where we lived when I was growing up
and my father sometimes would make me go
outside to take the tree branch
that he would hit me with
and so you can imagine if you're a 10 11
year old kid and you have to deal with
that what do you do well a hyper
Vigilant child learns how to basically
estimate the strength of these branches
right how far
can he go before it breaks
you have to estimate his anger and
estimate the effective strength of you
know branches and bring back something
because you know I remember these
moments where if it was
he would look at it and then he would
make me go out again and get it right
get a different one
um or you know there was a certain belt
that he wore that had this kind of um
belt buckle that stuck out
and you just wanted to make sure if that
if that was the thing that you were
going to get hit by
that it wasn't the Buckle facing out
because that really hurt
and so you became hyper aware of which
part of the Buckle was facing out versus
facing in in those moments
and there are like hundreds of these
little examples which essentially I
would I would say the through line is
that you're just so on edge
right and you walk into this house and
you're just basically trying to get to
the point where you leave the house
um and so in that microcosm of growing
up
any moment that's not like that is
seared in my memory in a way that I just
can't
describe to a person I'll give you an
example
I volunteered when I was in grade five
or six I can't remember which it was in
the kindergarten of my school
and I would just go and the teacher
would you know ask you to clean things
up
and at the end of that great five year
she took me and two other kids to Dairy
Queen
and I'd never been I've never I'd never
gone to a restaurant literally because
we just we didn't have the money
and I remember the first time I tasted
this you know this Dairy Queen meal it
was like a hamburger fries a coconut a
blizzard and I was like what is this and
I felt
so special you know because you're
getting something that most people would
take for granted oh it's a Sunday or
it's a you know or I'm really busy let
me go take my kid to to fast food I
think that you know until I left High
School
I think and this is not just specific to
me but a lot of other people it's
you're in this hyper Vigilant Loop
punctuated with these incredibly
visceral moments of compassion by other
people
you know a different example
um we had such a strict budget
and we didn't have a car
and so you know I was responsible with
my mom to always go shopping
and so I learned very early on how to
you know look for coupons how to buy
things that were on sale or special
and we had a very basic diet because you
have to budget this thing really
precisely
but the end of every year
where I lived there was a large grocery
chain called Loblaws
and Loblaws would discount
a cheesecake from 7.99 to 4.99
and my parents would buy that
once a year and we probably did that six
or seven times
and you can't imagine how special we
felt myself my two sisters we would sit
there we would watch the you know the
New Year's Eve celebration on TV we
would cut this cheesecake into you know
five pieces
it felt like everything
um
so that's sort of how you know my
my existence when I was at that age is
For Better or For Worse that's how I
remember it
the hyper vigilance Loop is that still
with you today what are The Echoes of
that this told you today the good and
the bad if you put yourself
in the mind of a young child
the thing that that
does to you
is at a very core basic level that says
you're worthless
right because if you can step outside of
that and you think about any child in
the world they don't deserve to go
through that
and at some point by the way I should
tell you like I don't blame my parents
anymore it was a process to get there
but I feel like they did the best they
could
and they suffered their own issues and
enormous pressures and stresses
and so you know I've really for the most
part forgiven them
how did you start to interrupt let go of
that blame
that was a really long process where
I would say the first 35 years of my
life
I compartmentalized and I avoided all of
those memories
and I saw external validation
right going back to this self-worth idea
if you're taught as a child that you're
worthless because why would somebody do
these things to you
it's not because you're worth something
you think to yourself very viscerally
you're worth nothing
and so then you go out and you seek
external validation maybe you try to go
and get into a great College you try to
get a good job you try to make a lot of
money you try to you know demonstrate in
superficial ways with the car you drive
or the clothes you wear
that you deserve people to care about
you
to try to make up for that really deep
hole
but at some point you it doesn't get
filled in
and so you have a choice
and so for me what happened was in in
the course of a six-month period I lost
my best friend and I lost my father
and
it was really like the dam broke loose
because I the compartmentalization
stopped working because the reminder
of why I was compartmentalizing was gone
and so I had to go through this period
of disharmony
to really understand
and Steel Man his perspective
and can you imagine trying to do that to
go through all of the things where you
have to now look at it from his
perspective and find compassion and
empathy
for what he went through
and then I shift you know the focus to
my mom and I said well you were not the
victim actually you were somewhat
complicit as well because you were of
sound mind and body and you were in the
room when it happened
so then I had to go through that process
with her and steal man her perspective
and at the end of it I never Justified
what they did but I've been able to
forgive what they did
um I think they did the best they could
and at the end of the day they did the
most important thing which is they gave
me and my sisters a shot by emigrating
by giving up everything by staying in
Canada and doing whatever it took
between the two of them
to sort of claw and scrape together
enough money to live so that my sisters
and I could have a shot and I'm very
thankful for them could they have done
better obviously
but I'm okay with what has taken place
but it's it's been a long process of of
that steel Manning so that you can
develop some empathy and compassion and
forgive
do you think if you talk to your dad
shortly after he died and you went to
that process or today you'll be able to
have the same strength
to forgive them
I think it would be a very complicated
Journey
I think I've learned to be incredibly
open about what has happened
and all of the mistakes I've made
I think it's it would require him to be
pretty radically honest about confirming
what I think he went through
because otherwise it just wouldn't work
otherwise I would say let's keep things
where they are which is I did the work
you know with with people that have
helped me obviously but you know it's
better for him to just you know kind of
hopefully he's looking from some place
and he's thinking
it was worth it I think he deserves to
think that all of this because you know
I think the Immigrant
challenge we're not even the Immigrant
challenge the lower middle class
challenge anybody who really wants
better for their kids and doesn't have a
good toolkit to give it to them
some of them
just they choke up on the bat they just
get so agitated about this idea that all
this sacrifice will not be worth it
that it spills out in really
unproductive ways
and I would put him in that category
and their self
evaluation introspection they have
tunnel vision so they're not
able to often see the damage they did I
mean I've I know uh like yourself
a few successful people that had very
difficult relationships
with their dad and you take the
perspective of the dad
they're completely in denial about any
of it so if you actually have a
conversation there would not be a deep
honesty there uh and that I think that's
maybe in part the way of life
yeah and you know I remember pretty
distinctly after I left and in this you
know in my middle 30s where
you know by all measure I had roughly
become reasonably successful
and my dad didn't particularly care
about that which was so odd because I
had to confront the fact that you know
whether it was a title or money or press
clippings he never really cared he moved
on to a different set of goals which was
more about my character and you know
being a good person to my family and
really preparing me to lead our family
when he wasn't there and that bothered
me
because I thought I thought I got to the
finish line and I thought there was
going to be a
metal you know meaning like I can tell
you Lex you know he never told me that
he loved me
I'm not sure if that's normal or not it
was my normality and I thought there's
going to be something some gold star
which never appeared
and so that's like a hard thing to kind
of confront because you're like well now
what is this what is this all about
um was this all just kind of a a ruse
but then I realized well hold on a
second there were these moments
where in his way again
putting yourself in his shoes
I think he was trying to say he was
sorry he would hold my hand
you know and he would interlock the
fingers which I felt is that's a really
intimate way of holding somebody's hand
I think
um so I remember those things so you
know these are the things that are just
etched in at least in my mind and
at the end of it you know I think uh
I've done a decent job in repairing my
relationship with him even though you
know it was posthumous it does make me
wonder in which way you and I we might
be broken and not see it it might be
hurting others and not see it well I
think that when you grow up in those
kinds of environments and they're all
different kinds of this kind of
dysfunction
but if
what you get from that is that you're
not worthwhile you're not you're less
than many many other people
when you enter adulthood or you know
semi-adulthood in your early 20s you
will be in a cycle where you are hurting
other people
you may not know it
hopefully you find somebody who holds
you accountable and tells you and loves
you enough through that
but you are going to take all of that
disharmony in your childhood and you're
going to inject that disharmony into
whether it's your professional
relationships or your personal
relationships or both
until
you get to some form of rock bottom and
you start to repair
and I think there's a lot of people that
resonate with that because they have
each suffered their own things that at
some point in their lives have told them
that they're less than
and um and then they go and cope
and when you cope
eventually those coping mechanisms
escalate and at some point it'll be
unhealthy either for you but oftentimes
it's for the people around you